go i don't know we have to apologize we
have to apologize we've had this
conversation many times before mafia
states americas has been a big kid do we
think this many thousands of people were
gonna order this in the first three four
days no we we had a number for the first
month and that was not the case
it was
record-breaking the commentary is
unfreaking believable here's just some
of the comments of people saying on
twitter on youtube on facebook all over
the place just this sit down alone was
gangster thanks to all what a tremendous
job patrick with the universities who
made the search uh maybe the best
interview of all time watching it all
over again it's amazing four episodes
and totally worth the wait well done pbd
congrats can you go to the next slide
because i wanted to be more about the
show the godfather just took a knee
there's a new boss in town mafia states
america will go down in history as one
the one the three greatest pieces of war
concerning the largest criminal
enterprise in the nation's history aside
from the government way to go
valuetainment bringing these two men
together and mayor in this fashion puts
to sleep every movie book podcast and
interview prior best of luck on your
next project
because this will be hard to top in
closing let's go
wow what an amazing sit down by george
cortez i would i could watch this a
million times over and never be tired of
it would love to see a second sin down
answering more questions mobber related
like jfk the mob uh wives series etc etc
keep going to the next one uh uh uh this
beats hollywood anything out of
hollywood joseph c fuentes
likes uh holistic investing wow i knew
this was coming but you went the extra
mile amazing content as always great job
it's worth every penny uh mario certain
best way to spend 40 dollars beautiful
projects all the right questions asked
so many names shared to confirm that
both guys were a part of the life at the
time we were anyways there's like
hundreds of comments on this and emails
are coming left and right and a bunch of
people have already binge watched and
they're sending us messages they can go
to
mafiastatesamericalrightnow.com to order
the 10 episodes i will say one thing
that this made me think about
we talked to each other and we said if
we hit this many numbers of uh uh
subscribers to the show that watch it
we're gonna do our first feature film
right you know the number we've talked
about it right
the point i want to make to everybody
that's watching this if you
want to see somebody else get in the
marketplace to compete against
mainstream media support platforms like
this it doesn't have to be us if there's
somebody else that you see that's
willing to fight it go support him
support by buying a product subscribing
there's a lot of great platforms out
there as well but if you like what we're
doing with valuetainment you'd like to
see us doing a couple of feature films
with it's the heroes the capitalists the
heroes the entrepreneur though he wrote
any of those stories that we take to the
next level uh we're excited for all of
you guys that have supported us from day
one but now we're kind of going to the
next part because now things cost money
you know what's funny people said well
your interview with samuel garvano that
got 13 million views that probably made
you half a million dollars so i'm going
to creative studios i don't think people
fully understand how you don't have you
don't have to do no but let me tell you
what i want to show him okay i'm going
to creative studios right now and i want
to show this check this out
how much money you think sammy gravano's
interview
made i actually want you to guess
how much money
13 million
this is 13 million views from youtube i
want you to look at this okay what do
you think that's made in its lifetime
what do you think that's made in its
lifetime 100 grand how much 100 100 000
okay you ready here you go since
published a hundred thousand dollars
you said 250 what do you think 13
million views has made 250 000
no clue
here's how much 13 million 96 thousand
views has made
on sammy gravano can you say the number
am i looking at this like 11 500 that's
lifetime 11
500
what is a sammy gravano interview 13
million dollars because youtube doesn't
pay adsense and half the stuff he talks
about so that's so that's before they
nerfed you so kids what pat's telling
you is if you want to be an influencer
when you grow up you better you know
save your money have a day job
don't interview mobsters because it's
all right you just be trading crypto so
if you enjoyed this little short segment
from the podcast that we did here's
another short segment to watch or if you
want to see the entire podcast click
over here take care everybody bye-bye
[Music]